okay
yep
um
okay
so
good afternoon folks i'm going to be
brief
i have been getting a
briefing on average four times a week
since march from a group of public
health
experts on the state of coronavirus
and all aspects relating to it and uh
we heard today again which is the normal
briefing i get with two added experts
on the call um about uh
a range of issues we talked about
school openings we talked about the
distribution
of a vaccine if and when one arrives
and what plans are being made for we
talked about significant about the
racial disparities that exist
and how it is uh covert
19 is affecting different races
differently
and we talked about the continued lack
of
ppe protective equipment and
testing capacity and the like but uh
and uh i put out a comprehensive plan
over the last
three months on each of these things but
today
i want to talk about one thing very
straightforward
doesn't have anything to do with
democrats republicans or independents
it has to do with a single simple
proposition
every single american should
be wearing a mask when they're outside
for the next three months at a minimum
every governor should mandate
every governor should mandate mandatory
mask wearing the estimates by the
experts are
will save over 40 000
lives in the next three months
40 000 lives the people act responsibly
and uh it's not about your rights it's
about your responsibilities
as an american the fact is that as
americans are lining up to give
blood americans volunteer all their time
for food banks and local charities
supporting their neighbors that are in
need well this is no different
wearing a mask is less about you
contracting the virus although it does
help
depending on the mask but it's about
preventing other people
from getting sick wearing a mask will
give
the life of a clerk in your local store
your letter carrier
your child's teacher it will increase
their prospects of
not contracting the virus even though
it's uncomfortable
we're not used to it wearing a mask is
going to get our kids back to school
sooner and safer wearing a mask every
american wearing a mask outdoors is
going to get our businesses back
and to full strength long term and we're
going to get our country back on track
but again when i get occasionally
confronted
with a person in public about wearing a
mask
i say look this america
be a patriot protect your fellow
citizens protect your fellow citizens
step up do the right thing
do the right thing there's overwhelming
evidence
overwhelming evidence that the mask and
depending on the type of mask you wear
increases exponentially the prospect
that
you if you are a carrier and you don't
even know it
that you will not infect anyone when you
cough sneeze
sing shout a lot of people
are dying we're up over 160 000 people
dead so far
and i'll end by saying that it goes a
little goes back to
the study some months ago by
columbia university saying that we
didn't have to be this way if the
president
acted sooner would have saved just one
week earlier
would have saved 30 some thousand lives
two weeks earlier i think it was 51 or
57
000 lives i hope we've learned a lesson
hope the president has learned the
lesson but again
this is not about democrat republican or
independent
it's about saving americans lives so
let's
institute a mass mandate nationwide
starting immediately
and we will save lives the estimate is
r will save over 40 000 lives
in the next three months if that is done
now let me turn it over to my colleague
and running mate
she has a few comments to make
thanks that's what real leadership looks
like
we just witnessed real leadership which
is
joe biden said that as a nation
we should all be wearing a mask for the
next
three months because it will save lives
and the thing about joe that the
american people know
is that his role of leadership in our
country has always been about doing
what's best for the people of our
country best for their health their
well-being and for their families
that's what real leadership looks like
and when joe talks about his priorities
he knows and he cares about the fact
that we have as a nation
witnessed a hundred and sixty five
thousand people who just in the last
few months have died in our country we
know that those individuals represent
families loved ones grandparents parents
sisters and brothers aunts and uncles of
people who are mourning
their loss every day so what real
leadership
looks like is joe biden to speak up
sometimes telling us the stuff that we
don't necessarily want to hear
but we need to know and the need for
this mandatory mask wearing
um will also uh be about what joe has
articulated
and what a biden-harris administration
will do in terms of creating a pandemic
testing board to get tens of millions of
testing kits where needed
to build a public health jobs corps
hiring at least one hundred thousand
americans
to lead us through contact tracing
as soon as we take office and to chart a
clear path
forward for a safe and effective
vaccine and guarantee every american
every american equal access to it
by investing 25 billion dollars
which is joe's plan 25 billion dollars
in manufacturing and distribution and
when joe talks about this
i think it's important that the american
people looking at the election coming up
um ask the current occupant of the white
house
when am i going to get vaccinated
am i actually going to get vaccinated
because there may be some grand gestures
offered by the current president
about a vaccine but it really doesn't
matter
until you can answer the question when
am i
going to get vaccinated so again joe
biden is about real leadership in our
country
and um and i'm honored to be with you
joe thank you
what role do you see for senator